بالفعل وصلت قبل ساعه من الان الطائره
الاولى المحمله او التي تحمل على متنها
الكثير من الخبراء والمختصين في قطاعات
طبيه مختلفه اسعافيه وايضا بقطاعات انقاذ
تتحدث عن فرق متخصصه من الدفاع المدني
بالاضافه الى خبراء من مركز الملك سلمان
لتقييم الاوضاع والاحتياج الحالي في
المناطق المختلفه التركيه في الجنوب التي
ضربها الزلزال بالاضافه الى المناطق
السوريه
هنا في المطار حيث وصلت قبل قليل الطائره
الثانيه وهي المحمله بالمساعدات التي تحمل
على متنها اطنان من المساعدات الاغاثيه
والطبيه
والعلاجيه بالاضافه الى الغذائيه وهي
ستبدا وتستعد السلطات التركيه هنا في مطار
اوبو اضنه
للبدء بتنزيل هذه
المساعدات مباشره
لوضعها الاماكن المناسبه من ثم توزيعها
على المتضررين مباشره هنا في اضنه وفي
المناطق المحيطه في الحقيقه عندما وصل هذا
الفريق كان في استقباله عدد من المسؤولين
التركيين تحديدا نتحدث عن مسؤولين في
الهلال الاحمر او الفرق النقاديه
المتخصصه في تركيا التي كانت تنتظرها
للوصول هذا الفريق اكثر عن حاله الفريق او
الوضع الحالي للفريق الذي بدا وشكل هذا
الفريق هنا في الداخل العديد من المتخصصين
في الجوانب مختلفه في السعوديه تحدث عنه
هنا فريق البحث وانقاذ وهم عدد من
المختصين الذين وصلوا من قبل الدفاع
المدني يشاركون في هذه
في هذه العمليات التي ستبدا بعد قليل بعد
وصولهم مباشره بالاضافه الى طاقم كبير جدا
خالد من الهلال الاحمر السعودي وهو الطاقم
الاكبر ربما كاد كان احتياج تحدثت مع
المسؤولين هنا قالوا بان الاحتياج من قبل
من قبل السلطات التركيه على تخصصات نادره
متخصصه
وتحتاجها السلطات التركيه في هذا الوضع
للتعامل مع الحالات والاصابات بالاضافه
الى تواجد فريق نسائي مع الفريق السعودي
يشارك في الهلال الاحمر وهم سيبداون
بالتوزع مباشره او توزيعه مباشره على
مناطق مختلفه في
المدن التركيه بدعم اضنه والمناطق
المختلفه هم لن يكونوا متواجدين في
المستشفيات سيكون متواجدين في الميادين
المختلفه التي يحتاج فيها
الجانب التركي وكذلك المتضررين هذا الفريق
الطبي المتخصص في تخصصات دقيقه جدا وهم
وصلوا قبل ساعه من الان ويستعدون الى
مغادره المطار الذي بدا فعليا بشاهدت
مستقبل عدد كبير جدا من الطائرات كان
هنالك فرق من مختلف انحاء العالم من
عمليات الانقاذ شاهد فريق من انقاذ من
تايوان بالاضافه الى البرتغال وعدد من
الفرق الاخرى التي وصلت تباعا مع مركز
الملك سلمان
للاستعداد للدخول الى داخل هذه المدينه
التركيه وبدء عمليات الاغاثه بشكل مباشر
مركز الملك سلمان ايضا سيكون هذا هو طليعه
الجسر الجوي الذي بداه سيكون ايضا الجسر
الجوي مستمرا يوم غد وحتى الايام القادمه
بالاضافه الى تواجد فريق الخبراء
المختصين من قبل مركز الملك سلمان الذين
سيقومون بتقييم الوضع بشكل مباشر وبشكل
عاجل
لاستطلاع ايه احتياجات جديده يحتاجها
فبالتالي هذا الجسر مهم جدا بالنسبه
للجانب التركي له
كل جديد او كل حاجه يحتاجها الى الطائرات
السعوديه القادمه من السعوديه يوميا
ستحملها على اثرها هذه الاحتياجات الطبيه
والاغاثيه